and I am also here and I'm Pauline and
I'm here and I'm I'm red and I'm here
look we're gonna break in the wee what
we're gonna break in the wheel
s
hit it on me all right Papa
[Music]
[Laughter]
maybe like two or three times and I'm
like this is this is terrible like do
not do not Google do not look into that
that's uh I don't want to do it no I was
like this is so weird no I've never
found anything that was like oh this is
so cool I'm so glad I Googled myself
today
yeah
yeah so satisfying it's so good it's
also like I can't walk it slows down and
it's like
my astigmatism is not cut out
okay oh this is your least yeah I knew I
was gonna get this because this has been
coming up a lot lately yes I am not a
Swifty I hate to say it this air of my
life using a Taylor Swift album would be
um Taylor Swift's song Thug Story
featuring T-Pain or it's T-Pain
featuring Taylor Swift I'm not sure I
know every word actually I could wrap a
word for it but I won't do that and now
you can't find it on the internet so
yeah foreign
[Music]
wait Bella she's saying everyone hello
yes no yes
this is when I realized I have to work
on my humor no you don't no you don't no
you don't I understood to be clear I got
it I was behind and that is on me yeah
my eyes
[Music]
okay I'll let you know what it says all
right okay fate What's it gonna be oh I
know the answer to this what is it have
you ever eaten a food you dropped on the
floor oh hell yeah thank you she does
absolutely absolutely if it's on my
floor at my home or elia's floor and he
is home first of all hers is more
trustworthy than mine what about food at
a restaurant floor no not at a
restaurant not even on a restaurant
table but when I was a kid
I did eat food up before once and I said
that's not that sorry and I said that uh
it was just a little ground seasoning so
true
and it was a joke in it in fifth grade
everyone died and I was like damn am I
hilarious
it's so stressful
who is my childhood celebrity crush oh
there were a lot I would say all of the
Backstreet Boys all right all of NSYNC
very into Britney Spears Christina
Aguilera the way they dress like very
sexy definitely wanted to be them Leah
Schreiber
an actor
very handsome those are my
um answers we told our truth so now we
dare you to watch season two of the sex
slides of college girls
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]